i can't believe this people are mad at
barry weiss again
barry weiss uh
people are angry with her because she uh
wrote something um
where you got to go on twitter she wrote
uh
something she's trying to get pregnant
by the way okay with her uh
uh partner nelly and and
it's been difficult for her and do you
know why it's it's been difficult
it's been difficult for her she's trying
to get pregnant with a bomb
so it's very it's very hard because they
keep wanting her to have a human baby
but she keeps she said it'd be more
she'd be more comfortable with the
missile
so that's it's been very difficult for
her now
it's been hard now she and she did say
it's very tiring
to get pregnant while advocating a
genocide it's very
trying so she wrote something where she
was basically like hey
uh zionism every now and then we gotta
just uh
go in there and she has a quote it's
pretty disturbing okay where it's
basically like
uh i don't know if she meant to say this
but it does come off negative
quote the results of this masses always
are especially bad for the palestinians
who live under hamas rule
hamas rule casualty reports are hard to
verify because hamas controls the media
even the international press
inside the gaza strip but it appears
that more than 50 palestinians have been
killed
here's what people are upset about this
quote some of these people are entirely
innocent non-combatants including
children
this is an unspeakable tragedy it is
also one of the unavoidable burdens of
political power and
power of zionism's dream turned into the
reality of self-determination
well that's not great what she's saying
is that the dead children
and the innocent people that have died
are an unavoidable burden of political
power of zionism's dream turned into the
reality of self-determination
it's a little callous it's a little
callous for someone who's trying to get
pregnant
right as a little callus what are we
doing her podcast
the ninth we'll be free that day
probably what we love is getting booked
on things and then seeing if we can free
up our day so we can go have lunch
and i have no issue with barry outside
of some of the crazier things she said
i understand people make her out to be
like some ghoul
this isn't helping that but i mean she
has said some things that make sense
this one i don't know makes sense it's
very strange to be uh picking out
furniture for nursery and then also say
hey
every now and then uh zionism's gotta
come in
and uh get kill the babies that's a
tough
you know it's just ironic she's actually
like trying to get pregnant
during this time you know
it's almost like she says to the doctor
she goes and don't worry if
my child acts up and goes against israel
i will also
realize that they must be killed because
it is one of the burdens of political
power
the doctor's like uh okay
all right thanks for coming in it's
getting wild over there
i i you know israel netanyahu's taking
that country in a very like right-wing
crazy
thing also the other side is that people
think hamas is like a theater group
that's also not true so i'm just an
irish catholic from long island really
leave me alone i just don't care anymore
i know you're going to get mad at me for
saying that i know you're going to
listen i think the palestinians should
not live in those conditions that's
ridiculous
um but the real people who are suffering
right now
truly i mean yes yes
the people over there but truly it's the
people that are going out for their
first lunches and brunches
that have to deal with this horseshit
and i'm going to provide a way
for you to get out of talking about this
while you're out at your first lunch
the post-quarantine lunch these are
things that i've seen my father do his
entire life
and they really they really do help
start we're at a lunch right now start a
conversation about israel and palestine
uh did you see the israeli strike
destroyed the gaza nothing with
very sad not good
not good it's a mess
you got a mess yeah the al jazeera
building it's uh
oh boy you got these ones and then those
guy i mean and forever it's been going
on forever
it's bad yeah the us said this is social
crab out of season
i think it is it's it's out of season in
the spring
but that's all right i love the grouper
but
stick to it's bad it's a mess
what a long time i can't believe it
i just want peace just say that guy just
i just want peace i hope they figure it
out
i hope they figure it out i just want
peace then steer the conversation into a
fish dip
because there's nothing you can do all
these people that are tweeting and
i understand that but there's nothing
you could really do
uh there's probably quite a blackmail
operation going on
that the massage has been doing for a
little while that's right joe biden i
mean
these people really can't say anything i
mean this is a guy that what made out
with 11 year olds what does he have to
hide
and so you get to a point where you go
yeah we're kind of
you know all of our political leaders
for the most part are are kind of
blackmailed
and then you have people like ilhan omar
who thinks that uh
you know we should just the white guys
have to go in the camps so it really
isn't
it's there's no way out so what you just
do
is try to avoid the conversation uh
because politics uh can really ruin
what is a lovely lunch
that's what it is it's time to get out
of your post-quarantine
relationships if you were in a
relationship with somebody i don't mean
if you met in the last couple of months
but i mean
if you were in a relationship with
somebody when they shut down the nba
it's time to call it quits
out leave your wife um
leave your husband get out get out now
because it's over say it was very fun
wearing masks with you
but it's time to go and this is awkward
people are watching this their bed right
now smoke on a joint
you know the end is an eye you know it
you know come july you were gonna be
you were gonna be out of there i mean
just
window open and [ __ ] sheet tied down
as a rope climbed out
out done this includes even some
friendships like
you gotta shake it up keep moving the
quarantine was a very interesting time
for a lot of people
but you gotta go now you can't keep
beating the dead horse these
relationships a lot of them were trauma
bonding you gotta just get out
reconnect later maybe not no
don't maybe i don't know but i'm telling
you a lot of relationships i'm seeing
them
myself i go and also move
move you're not going to want to live
where you quarantined you just go
somewhere else for a year
you know rehabilitate yourself
get somewhere else in your own life and
then go back i'm telling you right now
leave your wife and kids right now leave
your husband and children
destroy your family it's time
this year's about you
it's about you it's not about the others
this is a year of selfish hedonism
it's a year of disgusting libertarian
values
it's a year of horrible things
anti-society behavior just
glorifying every impulse eating s'mores
out of a stranger's [ __ ] in a subway
platform that's what this year's about
it's not about anything else don't miss
it
you're gonna have to do it i'm telling
you i know it's hard
to look at someone you went through this
whole thing with them and it's like
you guys are like yeah you know and
you're like should i propose
the answer is no you have to go out
experience other things are you and your
wife gonna break up
no we're happily together but that you
knew each other before the quarantine
yes a long time
that's why it works but if you had met
during the quar i mean it's just you
gotta go
and this is why israel and palestine are
having issues in my estimation
truly i don't think there were problems
before this
i don't know if there were but i haven't
read about them
this is a cuffing season quarantine like
okay we wore masks together we watched
the news together we figured out who
anthony fauci was
and now you have israel who's like more
powerful in a relationship but you have
palestine who's like a dirty freaking
bed
and then you have these two people and
now they're just not seeing eye to eye
they have to like
amicably break up do you understand
because
kwar is over and is and pal
have to go but they can't bother their
friend tim
who's just on the other side of the
world finally
mask off enjoying a lunch i don't have
to have talking points about this
i don't have to go through talking
points i
this is the summer of no talking points
telling you right now
the summer of no opinions oh your
mother's a rape to your sister yeah
all right the summer of no opinions
you just had four years of opinions what
did that do nothing
the summer of no opinions the summer of
yeah man don't know if it's not fun
not doing it it's got to be fun water
park
build a fort try drugs again
maybe you can handle them this time
booze it up
drink and drive a little not a lot but
if you have three
four in you and i mean cocktails not
beers always get in a car with three or
four beers [ __ ]
but i mean if you if you're feeling it
or you got four cocktails
and it's a late afternoon and you're not
gonna get popped get in there and feel
what it feels like
to control a vehicle drunk
light a butt blast so lonely by the
police
this is that summer this isn't a summer
about making documentary films
this is a summer about letting it go a
little bit
having a little fun fly somewhere to
suck someone off
buy a plane ticket to suck someone's
[ __ ]
and have them give you a whatever a
return
[ __ ] but that's what this summer's
gonna be about
and this is really starting to ruin it
and i don't want to see that i want to
see
people being happy on the beach remember
quarantine was so [ __ ] up but now
we're happy
because we can make 15 000 a year at
sonic
and everyone is going to be out this
summer and i mean everyone so you got to
pick and choose your places
it's going to be a little grotesque out
there the tits are out the fat [ __ ]
are going to be out
you're going to be you're just going to
have a fat [ __ ] put right on your table
as you're reaching for a handful of
calamari it's gonna be a wild summer you
gotta get ready wet and wild
bad bad disgusting people just vomiting
puking oding left and right
giving birth on the middle of a dance
floor that's where we're headed to
it's gonna get [ __ ] nuts masks off
tits
out people living on borrowed money and
borrowed time
you're gonna be getting stimulus [ __ ]
do it don't waste the summer in long
meaningless conversations in brooklyn
with some other loser and a knit sweater
but actually but i really think shut up
let's [ __ ] what are we doing
life is too short take this pill
let's kill someone together let's murder
my mother
that's what this summer's about
courtney stodden people like her
geniuses what do you think about israel
and palestine
i i think i stand with palestine wow
you know what that would have been
harder for us to say but they just
passed on our movie
and you know who didn't pass on our
movie hamas
so that's what happens we just fine we
don't want to be in the industry anyway
you know
so great it would have been nice to have
a film but what are you gonna do what
are you gonna do who cares
we're having enough fun here but that's
my advice for this summer
check out find some new people enjoy
some things travel
in make your life meaningful this summer
in any way that you can if you can
i know it's hard out there the whole uh
first half of the show
we showed you how [ __ ] people are
we're not blind to that
but i'm saying even in any little small
way that you can
get away from the people that you spent
just quarantined with it is essential
it is really essential that you leave uh
because i think you want to have a
little bit of an adventure
and this quarantine was kind of a weird
inverted adventure
where it was like a slumber party uh for
a year
and everybody was in their pajamas and
you can't go out now
we're we're heading back out and we're
gonna come out in the world very
sloppily
you know you ever see like a horse like
a baby horse
where after just give birth it can like
barely walk and it's covered in like
after birth
that's what people are going to look
like walking into clubs and restaurants
just
covering after birth not even able to
walk
just being led to their seat that's
what's gonna happen but you have to
embrace that just for the summer and
then in the fall get serious
get serious but this summer you should
be having sweaty
uh sex with people that you don't know
even if you're not gay you should be
having gay sex
you should bring another man into bed
with you and your wife
a man of color